[Music]
now the former
south african president jacob zuma has
given five days to hand himself in
after judge sentenced him to 15 months
in jail
zuma's been found guilty of contempt for
failing to appear before an inquiry
investigating corruption
during his time in office zain basravi
has its report
for the first time a former south
african leader
is facing jail time jacob zuma has been
ordered to surrender himself to police
within five days
he was sentenced to 15 months for
failing to appear at a corruption
hearing
the constitutional court judge's
decision leaves the former president
with few legal options
and the extent to which mr zuma has
attempted to justify his defiance
through public statements is of no
relevance
the statements were not formally pleaded
so fault to be disregarded
the constitutional court can do nothing
but
conclude that mr zuma is guilty of
the crime of content of court
zuma resigned from office in 2018 after
his own party threatened
to pass a vote of no confidence against
him over allegations
of high-level financial corruption and
graft during his time as president
and deputy president he's always
maintained his innocence
but has not cooperated with
investigators may i ask you then
as to how you plead to the charges that
have been put to you
i plead not guilty allegations against
zuma include many titans of industry
whom he is said to have allowed to
plunder state resources
and influence state policy south
africa's chief justice has described
zuma's defense
and his attempt to garner public support
as insulting to the people of the
country
years of corruption scandals have left
south africa's new leaders
with an unenviable task of restoring
investor confidence
in africa's most industrialized economy
al jazeera let's speak to our
correspondent familia miller who is in
johannesburg the judge there pretty
damning in her ruling how is this
verdict gone down in south africa
well i think there's a couple of
different reactions
to this judgment by the constitutional
court
certainly observers commentators
academics
lording the court for the supremacy of
the rule of law
in that the constitutional court was
unambiguous when it said that
jacob zuma his actions have defied
the courts defied the commission of
inquiry
into corruption in south africa by him
not
wanting to testify at that inquiry
despite a number of appeals uh
including a court summons and so in
terms of of the supremacy of the
constitutional court south africa's
constitution
and that no one is above the law this is
very important
especially in the context of trying to
fight
large-scale corruption in this country
but jacob zuma also has his supporters
in the months that have preceded this
judgment he has said that he's been
vilified
that there's a political agenda against
him um
and that he's been treated unfairly and
that the constitutional court and other
courts are being used
to target the former president and there
are people who believe that
that this is part of a political agenda
in terms of the difficulties
the african national congress is facing
with regard to its fight to corruption
that party is divided and if people
were to be targeted or had to be charged
for being involved in corruption
there are a number of of high-ranking
anc individuals or leadership that could
potentially face the music and so this
is concerning for people who say
that the anc is being targeted the
former president's being targeted
and this isn't really about corruption
but really about
politics and what's going on in the
country at the moment so
there has been a mixed reaction to this
verdict to this judgment
and i suppose many are waiting to see
what happens within the next five days
when it's expected that jacob zuma
should hand himself over to police many
thanks for that for me to miller there
for us in
johannesburg we can get a little more
analysis on this joining us on skype
from cape town is sanusha naidu senior
research associate
at the institute for global dialogue
many thanks for joining us on the
newshour
look they could have fined zuma why do
you think the verdict was so strict
uh good afternoon i think the verdict
was strict particularly because
as your correspondent had indicated mr
zuma has constantly
tried many ways in which to manipulate
his
judicial process so he's constantly made
the assumption and
and made the accusation that he is part
of
a political campaign to discredit him to
target
him to malign him and so as much as he
theoretically says
that i want to have my day in court and
i'm willing to go to prison
if that if that is what will happen
he's not really giving any kind of
genuine commitment to those statements
he makes
he constantly argues that the judiciary
is biased against him he challenges the
legitimacy of the judiciary
and he challenges the credibility of the
judiciary he has also challenged
the the the constitutional court
justices as well as the various judges
in uh our judicial process he's also
went out and said that
they are targeting him and they have a
political agenda against him this has
caused a lot of tension on the ground
where the supporters of mr zuma have
come out
and made similar statements and also
gone to the point of threatening
uh the the the lives of judges and and
and basically putting those threats on
social media spaces so i think this
judgment is critical
to say to the to to the broader south
african public
that nobody even if it's mr zuma a
former head of state
he's not above the law but i think what
makes mr zuma's case even more important
and strategic
is that in that judgment read by the
constitutional justice campaign
she mentioned that you know mr zuma is
exceptional but not exceptional where
he's above the law he's exceptional
because
he was a former state president and he
knows
what the constitution says and he
actually took office
and he abided by the oath of that
presidency that he took so he is not
above the law in that context
sunush it's interesting uh just reading
through some comments from people on
twitter
uh very skeptical that he's actually
going to end up in jail
what do you think is going to happen is
he going to uphold or dear to this
mandate does he have a choice
um technically he doesn't have a choice
because this is the highest
apex court in the land this is the
constitutional court there's no higher
court than this there's no process
for his legal team to appeal this
decision there's nowhere to go
so technically speaking if he doesn't
abide by the ruling
and and and what the justices had ruled
in terms of giving him five days before
he then presents himself to a police
station uh
and and says i'm ready to be to serve
this 15-month sentence
then of course he is in he is in a
bigger set of
of legal uh dilemma and troubles but i
think what
what people are possibly feeling on the
ground and within the court of public
opinion
is that we've seen this before where mr
zuma has come to this tipping point
and of course something happens and then
he's pulled back or something happens
and
he justice doesn't prevail but i think
this time around
it is going to prevail i think that at
the end of the day where i'm very
concerned
is what happens in uh the support base
of mr jacob zuma
especially those those sections of the
population and
in the party that support him and have
been guarding his house the mk
soldiers they incontinent soldiers of
the african national congress which is
not a legitimate
kind of uh association but they've been
standing guard outside his homestead in
kwazulu-nutel
in kanjur and they've been arguing as
well that they're not going to let
anybody put their hands on mr jacob zuma
so i think that for me is where
a lot of the challenges lie in terms of
the
powder keg and the explosiveness of what
transpires here after
and whether mr zuma uh does actually
present himself to the
to the police station he having said
that i think his family have indicated
in tweets
that they will actually take him to the
to to the core to the to the
police station because their argument is
that mr mr zuma is fearless he's not
afraid to go to
to prison and more importantly they want
him to serve this term
in kwazulu-natal his home province and
not in khao teng
so i think at the end of the day uh
there's indications that
you know he's going to go but i think
you know at the end on the other side of
the spectrum
is what the supporters do we'll have to
see he's gone five days sanusha naido
good to talk to you senior research
associate at the institute for global
dialogue